le chiffre est impressionnant plus 66%
aucun département français ne fait mieux
la hausse de la taxe foncière dans les
yvelines bat des records cette année de
7,58 % en 2015 à 12,58 % en 2016 soit
une hausse en moyenne par contribuable
225 euros et forcément la nouvelle passe
mal auprès des intéressés toujours des
hausses que ça pour les impôts pour tout
augmente malheureusement le pouvoir
d'achat lui n'augmente pas et voilà ça
fait beaucoup et
la marque je pense qu'à l'heure actuelle
ça fait mal au porte-monnaie pour tous
les français comme moi peut-être plus
plus encore pour les yvelinois
matraquage tout simplement 66% c'est du
matraquage
je peux comprendre que les décharges
mais faut pas exagérer quoi mise en
cause le département charge de l'impôt
se défend évoque notamment une hausse
des dépenses sociales type rsa mais
accuse surtout l'état et la baisse des
dotations une baisse qui atteint cette
année 38 millions d'euros pour le
département des yvelines
même mes collègues dans les autres
départements ne croyait pas que l'état
nous avait repris 90% de sa dotation
tous me disent c'est impossible puisque
dans les autres départements de l'ain a
pris 30 aux cornes pour ça il ya les ivy
dont était particulièrement puni pour
une raison très simple
elles dépensent peu elles sont économes
des deniers publics et elles ont une
fiscalité faible et quasiment pas de
dettes dans le gouvernement actuel ça
s'appelle de la mauvaise gestion on ils
le feront ceux d'autres départements ont
connu également une hausse importante de
leur taxe foncière en 2016 c'est le cas
par exemple du voisin essonniens + 29 %
pour un taux d'imposition cette fois-ci
de 16,37 %